okay for people who are joining us on
the live stream this is an internal
design meeting that's part of our
language completeness and consistency
series we have now a happily wrapped two
version 11.3 so this is discussion of
things for future versions beyond eleven
point three okay let's pick up the first
item read list versus read string read
byte array what on earth is all of this
is this different behaviour of these
different functions you right so so if
you have an empty file and you just say
read a file you get end a file which is
basically the only thing Reed can do
because Reed opens the file and attempts
to read the first expression and then it
leaves it open if right if you call read
list on this empty file you get an empty
list because it didn't read anything and
the behavior of read list is to open the
file read everything it can close to
file so I would have expected rate
string to behave the same way as read
list if you open if you asked it to read
string an empty file it opens it up says
oh there's nothing here return a null
string and then close to file now it
does the first and the last of the steps
but in the middle it returns in the file
now okay hold on let me understand that
so is there a difference between so a
file that doesn't exist is gonna give an
error so this is actually an empty file
yep so wide enough isn't it returning
just a null string right so is it a bug
so this is arguably a bug the
documentation says that when the source
has been exhausted it returns and the
file or what was about buffers and a
buffer of available content what's that
run not for devices yeah so that would
be if here
to read from a process or some kind of
buffer any kind of stream with the
buffer rather so that as an end of that
specific buffer rather than the entire
file itself but so okay but aren't there
different kinds of files on their files
where it either is a string where you
can definitively read it wait a minute
it's reading to a terminator right so
that's the other case here so your
argument is go ahead your I mean it
could be a read string that gives and a
buffer
but you don't read string again right
because it does the open closed business
is that right well no so if it's reading
from a process or stream that is already
open then it doesn't close it it just
goes from the current point I so then
been multiple read strings could at one
time return and a buffer and the later
time returned content because the buffer
got extended right although they don't
actually return and of buffer they
return an empty string
well it says they returned under oh the
Terminator can say on the buffer right
well okay so that's the specification of
the Terminator which is different from
the specification of what it
returns correct correct and so right and
so there certainly case it right so you
might want to distinguish between oh is
there just nothing right or suppose you
say read until you encounter a new line
but you're right at the new line so you
might get an empty string bag so it
certainly makes a certain amount of
sense that you can sort of differentiate
between rake I'm there isn't there's an
end apply them at the end of file yes as
opposed to just to the Terminator there
was nothing to read correct so that's
not completely stupid been exactly so
but what I think we could do is special
case when restring opens reads a whole
file and then closes it and if that file
happens to be empty rather than
returning and a file returning an empty
string right so if the if they agree
that that case seems very awkward that
but why not special case the one
argument form right because the two
argument form is the only case where and
a file as a useful differentiator
right in the one argument case there's
no read to terminator in the one
argument case is just going to gulp the
whole thing right of so you might
already be it in the file
or what if you set time constraints to
something then you might want to
differentiate between I at the end of
the file and I ran out of time to read
the full file or to even read anything
from the file yes so Jeremy are you
suggesting we shouldn't special case
anything or just that we should restrict
to the open closed case we might not
want to risk to special case anything
but at least in the single argument case
we would not want a special case it if
it had a finite time constraint what's
the argument to special case the
argument to special cases you just want
to read the damn file and if the file is
empty you wanted a null string
you don't want messing around with end
of end of file where you have to do all
kinds of crazy code to work around that
is that is that it is that the correct
thing I think so
right because certainly if you think of
you know if you think of read string as
you know from character code of read
lists the comma character rate young or
no I agree so but look the time
constraint thing um I don't like that
that unspecial casing the thing with
time constraint I think that's very hard
to understand at a document so is there
any second argument that could lead to
the behavior you want with time
constraint which is to return and a file
yes the answer is that the second
argument should be and a file right in
the case where and if the second
argument is and a file
you
then you would explicitly return and a
file if you hit the end of file and not
if you don't am I making sense
I don't understand something okay if
you've got a time constraint there and
you try and read and you've got a
thousand characters for example right
and they ran out of time constraint
there's no way to distinguish that from
you got a thousand characters in it and
and it ran into the end of the file
because you don't explicitly return end
of the file you know in other words if
you successfully read a strain just
return the string right so that case
doesn't disambiguate either correct so
do we have or need an end of file queue
or something like that I believe we have
or Dewey I think we do but I think the
right thing to do here is the special
case the one argument form regardless of
whether it has a time constraint if they
really want the behavior of showing you
whether you hit the end of file or not
then
use the Terminator and a file but I
don't see how you can know what is the
indicator that tells you whether you got
the whole string or not in a time
constraint case I don't think there is
one
you'd have to you know go ahead add the
additional check for under file Q or
read again write only in the case that
there was actually nothing to read and
you're at the end of the file that you'd
get the indicator which which does seem
inconsistent which is why I think the
correct the differentiator is not is it
time constrained or is it one argument
versus two argument but rather is this
an open stream or not
right because bait right I mean reaching
already and it should be documented
somewhere that the rate that well if the
if the default Terminator and the file
is used then and that's and the file is
not already open
it'll open it and then close it if you
use a different Terminator or if the
stream was already open it we'll leave
it open at the end so so how does that
relate to this question of when you
return and else I mean the case that
seems to me useful is the file was not
open at the beginning you gulp the whole
file in and you just return a string
which is what I was just saying okay so
you're proposing that when when you're
gulping the whole file it always returns
a string correct even if you're actually
not gulping the whole file you're only
gulping to a terminator
I mean because that case also works
right the case where it wasn't open at
the beginning but you read to a
terminator and then close is that right
is that a case that that works no in the
case where it was not already open but
you read to a terminator which is not in
the file it will leave it open okay so
your proposal is that if it was closed
at the beginning yes and it returns a
pure string
no look if you ask it to read to
terminator and the Terminator never
comes it better return on the file
bright which is why I'm saying the
special cases you open your opening the
file and you're reading to end the file
okay then it would return a null string
great if there's nothing there it seems
reasonable to me I should think about a
little bit more I mean that's off the
top of my head that sounds reasonable
now is there more here I mean is there
also a byte array case here right so the
reason I noticed this is that read byte
array follows read string and so I was
surprised that an empty file is giving
me and the file rather than you know and
then Oh Pyke's exactly yes that seems
completely wrong I agree so far as I can
see this is right who else can you check
out who else so you got to try to check
it with I I'm not certain that we've
seen every corner here I think it's
pretty consistent this way I just want
to make sure it all makes sense okay the
way the data is proposing yes yeah the
way eToys proposing makes sense to me
okay anybody else who wrote an opinion
is there anybody else who should be
consulted I could send an email to teak
or design but it's a pretty subtle to
see yeah have you checked with Flip Rick
that that would make sense he's he's
been a bit a wall recently but let's see
if you can track him down and ask him um
who else might care about the you you
could send something to tea core design
if you can write it in a way that's
interesting enough that people will read
it um
okay next item then their raft
image size goes to rule so this is a
secret syntax for sizing images or
graphics from the inside out instead of
outside in yeah and then it specifically
for graphics not graphics 3d
what do you mean by putting the is this
something to do with the padding
business or what is it to do with I
think it makes the most sense to look at
a couple of these examples but the basic
idea is you're specifying the size of
the range rather than the size of the
whole blob
and maybe I see what you're saying you
you mean you mean whatever the plot
range is you say how big that's supposed
to be whatever decoration the thing
happens to have on the outside correct
so whatever legends and this isnt matts
it has and so this is clearly very
relevant to the multi panel graphics
project that true Bret it is related to
that although I don't think you know
it's not the case that we're necessarily
going to use that approach to implement
that but multi-panel graphics has the
possibility of aligning content areas
but yes correct okay so how is it going
to do it a bit more manually explain so
basically the approach I'm taking is I'm
breaking the graphics down into pieces
that are scalable and pieces that aren't
ok and then constructing them you know
constructing a final graphic carefully
from that are you exploiting the
implementation or you explaining the the
user level specification I mean at the
user level implementation okay level is
you know throw inside graphics grid with
a new option setting okay and it's
setting or is it going to default to
this because this is a really good
behavior in my opinion not entirely
decided yet okay fine but let's let's
cross that bridge later
I mean graphics good has a lot of
complicated issues of doing optimization
for different aspect ratios and so on
right and multi-panel still you know in
here it's quite a bit of that all right
okay fine
so not relevant to that okay so what
this is for then is
explain this is I mean so for example
this is the better way to do pixel
constraint in it and array plot I see
that's because you know yeah I
understand in tradition to be able being
able to say that you know the plot range
aka the Blue Square is a certain size I
think probably what you're saying is
there's the ability to say that one X
you know one unit in the x-direction
you know from say zero point zero to one
point zero is 50 pixels all right let me
see that
okay so what is that what is the actual
spec what's wrath justice a ref is
either automatic in which case it's the
blue rectangle or it's a size in the
coordinate system of the graphic right I
understand it so I mean we also have
things like image size padding and
things which in other words the question
of whether it's all doesn't image size
have some other wacky stuff in it that
involves maximum sizes of images and
things yes and they got sanitized a
little bit a couple versions ago right
where before it was you know up to would
be list and so you had these weird you
know two level of Lists sorts of some
taxes with single lists so here you've
got an interval right which I bet we
don't actually support interval itself
do we I doubt it will be a nice thing to
think about somebody is asking to
increase the font size on the screen
which we can probably do
one unit I'm not gonna go any more than
that because always we can't see enough
on-screen to do that right so if you
spell down the pointing out it's like
the newest CSS box-sizing property but
probably nobody in this meeting knows
about we can specify to extent the width
height properties apply to contents plus
padding plus border bus margin it's
interesting
I mean we don't think of them as being
named regions of the graphics right
for the most part now for the dogs we
have you know the diagram that has that
illustrates the scaled versus image
scaled coordinate systems where you know
scaled is the blue and right so here is
you know what is content area what is
decoration and the point is that what
you're saying is that there's a very
definite sense of size because we
actually have an intrinsic coordinate
system this won't be the case in like a
CSS type story because we actually have
you know we have data that we're
actually plotting here so there's a
coordinate system defined by that array
tense and so when we say you know what
the size should be we could be saying
that that coordinate system I don't even
understand what this is what the heck
does the to mean here these two units in
the X direction so minus 1 to 1
oh that means X Direction okay that
explains one of the questions I had
further down I'm pretty sure it means X
Direction yeah we tend to be very
eccentric notice that note that our plot
range is 2 so these two things should be
equivalent and in fact they look very
equivalent yes but it's 2 in both
directions but if it wasn't if it was 2
and 18 or something this would mean that
an image size of 2 in the X Direction
corresponds to an image size of a
hundred in the X direction and what
would it do in the Y Direction see it
might one could argue that then what it
should do is have the Y Direction be 50
times 18 so to speak
well I think it'll be a Spectre a show
at that point if you which is what I
just said which will do what I just said
I think okay um okay so let's get a
sense of what else is going on here
separate sizes okay wouldn't earth does
this mean that means the
this one here okay that's probably the
easier one to write so this is saying
that one in the x-direction is 50 pixels
is this gonna run by the way can I just
run over yeah yeah
this is a case of you know this all
works
we just haven't documented it and I
don't really like the design so let's
take a look at this one here so that's
great but now what happens what I want
to do is I want to have a scene that
isn't symmetrical okay so if I say if
the scene here is well just change the
part range add an explicit plot range
which is whatever you want it to be
okay so minus 1 1 and let's say 0 5
so that I'm guessing is a hundred pixels
wide and what 250 tall now yeah 250 tall
I think this is utterly obscure I mean
look the image size here what you're
doing I mean what one would think is
that this image size would give the
image size
so right right this says that one pixel
in the x-direction is 50 pixels one unit
in the X direction so that minus one to
one is a hundred pixels and it says that
two units and now this is why we're
proposing a new a new name for this so
rather than using rule we call the
proposal is that we call it range scaled
right because it's basically telling the
scale of the plot range notice we also
have magnification that I don't know how
it plays in graphics but in image it's
very identical to image size it actually
gives that magnification you have in the
right hand side of the roof sorry I
don't know Sun so you're saying that if
I would give an M exercise for an image
what are you saying so if I if I make an
image here picture of a goat well
basically for images image size and
magnification play exactly the same role
if you have two that are not matching
one I think
image size so if I say image of this
coma magnification arrow - mm-hmm then
I'll get a bigger goat right and if I
say this thing if I say image of the
goat coma image size arrow let's say
5,500 the
mr. padding right yep then I got a
pallet goat right
images we don't have something like
magnification goes to list one comma two
so that you can scale only in one
direction but it seems like the design
here is going towards that it's just too
a list of two different magnifications
for X&Y
yes I'm not sure that it's really
magnification right it's certainly not
magnification as graphics understands it
um or the front-end understands it
personal from the livestream whose name
seems to be written in Japanese so I
can't read it
it's guessing that it's in that the
purpose of all this is to achieve pixel
accuracy is that also what the width and
height ranges in the currently open
documentation is supposed to choose
automatically no the whole point is what
the image size refers to that is does it
refer to the outer boundary the yellow
outer boundary of the graphic or does it
refer to the blue inner boundary and it
is certainly true that to achieve pixel
precision on a graphic like an array
plot you need to be able to describe how
the how many pixels are in the blue area
so let's go back to your proposal let's
is there a proposal coming down to the
bottom it's at the top which is
basically we change instead of using
Rothko societies we use a new name plot
so there's a type of there that's
supposed to be plot scaled right so we
have scaled the truth today did we say
plot plot scale range scaled I don't
know what I was thinking when they type
that is it's wrong but okay go ahead I
mean yeah what we've got right now is
image scaled right image skills is the
coordinate system that goes 0 0 at the
bottom left corner of the yellow
rectangle 2 1 1 at the top right corner
of the complete image of the yellow
rectangle yes right so I think that plot
scaled would be the correct analogous
thing of the plot range area
so arguably plot scaled so the question
is could plot scale work the same way
that image scale works I mean I'm not
sure that I agree with the name plot
scaled but really could it work the same
way that image scale works
I mean image scale is a coordinate
system okay what do you propose plus
scale this right so it's it's it's a
size right it's a size specification
it's it's not like image scale that's
like scaled well scales is also a
coordinate system but you can say image
size goes to scaled can you say image
size goes to image scaled
what you mean you can say image says
goes to scaled okay okay so sorry yes
you can say image size goes to scaled I
think but that's in terms of you know
that's a container that it's within
exactly
I mean scaled as a size is a general
boxy construct right it means as a size
of whatever holds me okay but okay let's
return to the question of what
functionality we're trying to achieve
here okay what we're trying to do is
we're trying to say that some particular
let's write down you know some
particular user coordinate range is
mapped to a particular image size a
particular essentially image range
- you know although it doesn't show it
you know this is sort of the same
mapping as a scale bar on a map right
you have this distance in the picture
corresponds to some other you know
real-world distance maybe this is an
inverse of that you know but well what
would be what you want it in particular
the special cases you want are
essentially the all goes to you know
width and height pixel width and height
and then you also want a
cific Pixlr yes he will plot court dxdy
goes to P X P Y a certain number of
pixels P X P Y right yes in this case
here is really that that is really the
case of whole DX whole dy goes to whole
W whole H is that correct system by all
you mean the yellow rectangle or the
blue blue okay so so right now that's
automatic well let's call this ottoman
yes okay I was changing it to all
because I don't really believe in that
right I mean I don't think automatic is
necessarily all right if we construct
some new syntax as sugar for this
low-level construct I agree that all
would be a better replacement than
automatic you know what I would prefer
because really what this is is it's an
image size scaling it's saying this
input in the plot turns to this size
well except it's not really applying on
top of the current image size that's
correct which is a bad reason for this
name but the concept of having a
separate option that would essentially
trump image size if it's specified seems
okay so the issue is that this I mean we
do have a hierarchy of options so image
size doesn't necessarily have to be the
king of the hill so to speak go ahead my
guess is that any syntax you come up
with this would work just as well using
image you're extending image size
instead of adding this a new option
okay well you know in that you still
have these two pieces of information
that you need to package somehow do that
through a new option or if you just
extend image size it'll be okay okay
okay let's try this concept to a plot
scale okay
so image size can image size have a
scaled as the right-hand side yes what
does it mean it means you know relative
to what's inside what that graphic is
inside of so if you do graphics of disk
image size goes to scale point five it
should be you know about half the width
of your notebook
you
you
okay and I forget how it deals with
maybe its height of the notebook no no
that's what that's what that's what Oh
put nine sorry yeah if I do that it's
going to be you know the job my creature
okay okay great that's beautiful
okay so what's your so then is there an
analogy to that I don't see an analogy
to that this because this is a scaled
this thing you're proposing this range
scaled thing is a scale is a creature
that is scaling relative to its
container
correct
and so my thought was range scaled is
something that's feeling relative to the
plot range that's how I came up with the
name now if you want to suggest a better
name I'm all ears boy we're a range
scaled is scaling relative to what the
plot range yeah but that's really weird
because that's an inside feature of the
plot this scaled is with respect to
something that contains that envelops
the whole graphics object right but I
mean image scale is something that
scales with respect to the yellow area
rate what does that even do what is that
what did that just do I'm not sure you
can use it as a suspect I think you can
only use it as a positional thing in
theta graphics well this should do
something or should generate a message
you have no idea what that did okay well
anyway that's a separate problem um okay
so the question here is you're defining
a trend you're defining this case here
of the sub dxdy do we even want that
case yes we do want that yes is we want
to be able to say I mean that's the
basic of the pixel constrained case one
pixel in one unit goes to four four
pixels for example or four six pixels
which will change its aspect ratio right
and I mean to be clear the reason I you
know bread and I even looked at this is
that people periodically request that we
document this and there have been I mean
Chris Carlson obviously has been a
strong voice on this but I'm pretty sure
we've got external a reasonable thing to
have so and this is certainly I had no
idea we had this capability this is
certainly useful and a lot less clunky
the pixel constrained I think now pixel
probably you would still use pixel
constrained pixel constraint is very
useful with pixel constrained is this a
new thing no drawers array plots where
you know each cell is an actual square
okay yes and where to align with display
pixels right and so that also I mean
that I think I don't know its
relationship to image size in fact it
really should say that here or its
relationship to image size this this
needs a bit more documentation yeah okay
I'm wondering if there's a name around
constrained fits well but let's
understand what this is the most common
use will be what will be the most common
use because
it's not
that a certain number of units so shadi
when you map isn't there a way of
mapping coordinate systems in graphics
so I'm sorry in images in images there
are two coordinate systems one is the
zero one coordinate system the other is
the pixel coordinate system how do you
deal with the zero one coordinate system
is that just with scaled we typically
don't most of the functions treat images
in the graphics coordinate system which
is zero with zero hi so within a single
function we typically don't change the
coordinate system that we're using okay
so you're saying an image for if I try
to put graphics on top of an image the
coordinate system that will be used as
the one in which one pixel is one unit
yes
okay so this again is saying this is
again another you know it's saying one
pixel as in DX or DX pixels maps to some
output number of pixels because this is
in pixels on in the the image size
function the image size option the
values are in pixels right right so what
this is doing is it's telling you the
mapping between the coordinate system of
the actual plot and the number of pixels
and your proposal is currently what it's
doing is it's saying all means
yeah it's pretty obscure this automatic
arrow with height it's pretty obscure
right which is precisely why we were to
say you know pushing to come up with a
new syntax prior to actually documenting
it what about the possible is something
like M exercise mapping as an Trump's
image size or the other way around
is the only possibility of using an
association on the right hand side of an
exercise that could say something
reasonable
what would the left-hand sides be I
don't know a specification of I mean I'm
trying to think what see the thing
that's bothering me is that this
automatic arrow width height is a little
bit clunky I mean so the automatic I
think could reasonably be scaled of one
or all it doesn't really help us none of
this stuff helps us what this is doing
is it's giving the image size I mean
okay so here's a proposal here's a
possible proposal maybe this is crazy
I'm going to suggest yeah I mean because
this is this is basically going to end
up with the same thing we had before
this is saying image size of that area
goes to this um the thing that's really
weird is this dxdy goes to pxpy away
that weird well it's only weird in the
context of in exercise because I mean I
have to say the syntax as done right now
it's seeming less crazy than it did at
the beginning of this discussion right
and actually I guess I didn't actually
write the remember to write this down
anywhere but I was thinking that the
what's currently are the man that goes
to width height could be just a one
argument form right so we have a range
scaled of you know fifty a hundred means
make the range range scale come from we
weren't talking about range scaled we
were talking about just look right now
this is the image size don't we have him
I was I was proposed so yes I wrote down
plot scale because I guess I was in a
hurry but it was such a in my third
bullet point in my notebook was supposed
to say I know but that wasn't what we
were discussing right now what we were
discussing right now is the the version
that is that is in there right now with
rules so I mean because these are the
cases I understand that what I am
pointing out is that we could avoid
right we could the what's currently
automatic goes to X Y if we had a new
head we call it yeah you know the
automatic goes to X Y could be a one
argument I can right I get it I just
don't like range scale because it's
doing the opposite way around I mean
scaled is what you are relative to your
container this is something about what
you are relative to your contents weight
so how about by range no I mean that's
that sounds horrifyingly
general all right let's look at let's
look again at what the current
specification for image size is okay
it's very much just giving him exercises
right so what would we do if we wanted
to say
yeah
this is basically an image size that is
it's not a multiplier it's an image size
from the user coordinate system
yeah I mean it's inside out okay here's
a possible idea plot range image size
now actually that raises the question of
if you give in the automatic case is it
actually of the plot range do you see
what I'm saying it's of the plot range
plus the padding it's of the actually
displayed plot range system so plot
range including plot range padding but
not image padding okay but so what would
happen if we call it plot range image
size okay so the one argument form of
that is this is the width and height
width the same all the same issues here
right yep for the plot range and in the
case where in the somewhat obscure case
where we're giving DX dy
[Music]
we would use this syntax here
seems not completely obscure to me
because the plot range image size gives
you a clue that it's something to do
with the plot range
what do you think they generally do not
object I wonder if there is a way to
eliminate the nested rule if we can get
away with making that double Lister or
something like that or if that's scaled
of some kind and I don't think the scale
will work yeah
no nothing the scaled will work but I
mean I would why you're proposing
something like see I don't think we can
do this because I think that syntax has
already been used in the plot in the in
the image size syntax min max min max
what does it mean wait a minute width
and height ranges how do you end up with
those oh I see I see I see I see
well this is my current proposal and
really the only difference here I mean
in principle this syntax could be
accepted by image size the only
difference is the default case here and
who wins
I think image size should win okay I
think it's the because it's the thing
that it's like you know I just want this
image to be a certain size and I don't
want you know random decorations hanging
out the window so to speak
in German Caesar plot range size I think
range of exercise because it's in pixels
now is there a function for which this
wouldn't be an appropriate thing I mean
like like a ray plot does it have what
does it think of it as being its plot
range it does have a plot range for its
X Y as well as its height right right
and it's say Y of 0 M 0 in sort of plot
range which is fine for this so that
then you can just say so just to be
clear one of the cases there would be
one and there's another interesting
question of whether we default to I see
one unit you know that's okay
that that that can be defaulted to it
you know a single unit that is a
different width as it is height
right a single unit in X&Y it
corresponds to a different width than
height right and you get rectangular
cells exactly right
so doesn't make sense or doesn't no
completely make sense are things you
know so so 3d does it make sense at all
yeah so this would strictly be a you
know graphics and derivatives option I'm
thinking about that comment for a second
sure yes you're correct I mean image
size image size might Center and that's
by the way another reason to not
overload the image size specification
because image size makes perfect sense
for 3d things but this particular thing
doesn't really as you say although I
mean this is the more specific option in
terms that it you know in the sense that
has you know a smaller scope of things
that it makes sense with maybe that
means it should win no okay no no
because but I also think you know in the
world of the future when there are
proper 3d displays there is a sense in
which plot range image size can make
perfect sense for a 3d display right yes
and then there's things like log plot
where the width height version of this
is fine but saying you know trying to
specify something in terms of DX dy is
not nearly as clear because it's because
because in the case of a log plot it
would want to be multiplicative right
right what the heck would it be I mean
what the heck would that be you'd know
the multiplicative factor
[Music]
you
know how a nurse would it mean something
look the scaling okay plot range for a
log plot is what it's the range of the
un-- logarithms values correct on which
end what I mean is that you know so if
you're doing a log plot you say plot
range goes to 1 comma 100 yep that is
specified in terms of the unscaled data
that's right right so the only
constructs the graphic that you know
essentially has plot range of 0 to
whatever log of 100 is so okay so I tell
you what this what will have to happen
here there has to be another syntax for
this and it looks like this this is it
has to go X min x max in other words it
has to look like a plot range so I'm
saying Y min Y Max and what this is
basically doing is it's telling you the
mapping from a plot range region to the
image size C that will then work for for
a thing like logarithmic log plots
because that can say 1 comma 100 you
know 1 comma 10 or something amazing I
was going to ask why isn't for log Potts
it's just using per decade or other than
or whatever the other original unit
steps are
and well and that possibly makes sense
for log plot but you know we also have
query scaling functions right so these
have to be those xmin xmax this is in
user coordinates and in the case where
it's a linear system dxdy makes sense
right in the case where it's a nonlinear
thing you've got to give the xmin xmax
and you can elide that to the case of
just a single one if it's linear and
everything's the same okay so I'm
believing in this option check it out
see if you can make this work okay
um in fact I even like it quite a lot
okay thank you okay let's go past the
goat um and we don't have really any
time left here but let's just have a
quick look at what else we have here
all right so my main objection here is
that we have network packet recording or
but audio record I know I know I know I
know I made a fuss about that as well
okay okay so shadi could speak to the
audio we already discussed this once
right what was the what was the
conclusion when we last discussed this
recording okay a capture function puts
up a UI yes okay
a recording function does what
does it put up a UI or not where it just
goes off it just records
okay so network packet recording records
for a certain time is that correct yeah
what does audio record do that can as
well require that two things no no but
that's not until you stop it I mean
that's a okay so that's generating an
audio stream which is yet a different
thing from what network packet recording
does now word packet recording is is
like device read time series it just
reads for a certain time right so
whereas audio record so listen to this
audio record is like a file open where
you poke around at the file and
eventually you close it so you do an
audio record you poke around you
eventually stop it okay whereas the
record ding is basically here's a time
just record for that time and then stop
right recording doesn't return okay
audio record returns an unfulfilled
still going stream object like thing
that you can then stop recording just
records for a certain time and then
returns the result okay that's the
difference and that's and that's a I
agree more work has to be done on
normalizing these things but there is a
difference between those two cases and I
even think audio recording makes sense
as just a thing where you give it a time
and it just records for that amount of
time and then stops does an audio record
have the max duration option it does but
I don't like it very much because it's
because remember what it's returning
okay Network packet recording returns
that the payload the results right audio
record does not return that it returns
some kind of audio stream object yes
okay so it's a different thing and I
personally think audio recording needs
to exist
you
okay well you could also do that with
audio capture
which is yet another syntax Steven
doesn't like I think well brings up a UI
and that's all it does that's all it
should do right right and if you're
saying necessarily bring up the UI there
is a hidden option there is an
undocumented option that can just record
in the background and great then what
I'm proposing is that that undocumented
option becomes documented and is audio
recording and that way we don't have the
embarrassment of an undocumented option
to do that we just bring it out into the
open as a function as it should be
mm-hmm so you give it a time and
possibly a file and then it returns the
audio object that is correct yep just
like Network packet recording okay well
we don't have okay we don't before you
beer off Steven yeah close that section
please and let's go back to the previous
okay we're running out of time I'm just
trying to triage these last two things
but what it what is it you're going to
attack during I'm going to attack during
and and frankly you know we don't use
Sharon's very much I'm aware I mean this
is a very weird case do you know what
this does let's start off with you know
what it does yes I do know what it does
it is a weird thing that it is doing it
is an inverse side effect dance so a
side effect would be you do something in
Wolfram language and it makes something
happen in the outside world yes this is
this is the inverse of that that is you
are
well yeah it's a very weird thing I mean
what it's doing is it's saying do this
whorfin language operation like URL read
for example and or URL execute and
record while you're doing this I mean I
don't know if anything else we have
that's even vaguely close to this which
is why I Jaron did it there's like the
it's really a different kind of thing
than anything else we've had well I mean
we have trace but you rate it's dude you
know record things while this thing is
executing turn enough trace is something
similar that's not terrible that's not a
terrible word trace is not a terrible
word to be associated with this
I mean network packet trace one could
imagine yeah I agree
could imagine that all right let's I
mean these are still all experimental we
need to you know we're about to start
the big round of D experimental ization
so let's please remember that for that
purpose let's have a very quick look at
this and then we gotta go well this
isn't a quick one we'll just punt this
next I just won't know what it is right
it was about
it's the second sub-point there we need
to discuss how to do deal with unicode
block how to deal with the option
unicode block in the case where it's
private unicode or some other case in in
general right that we determined that we
should not expose a unicode block
property and character name but we made
no discussion about whether we just have
it as an entity property or or what
because we don't have a character data I
don't think so
well we actually do have one of those
but it is no there is no character data
there's character name and there are
character entities but I see I see I see
character data was turned into character
entities and the problem with this is oh
boy
this is a mess yes I mean the problem
with that is it isn't an entity if it's
in private Unicode space and it isn't a
thing that is as a definite identity
that's the issue right because you might
have written something different into
that slot and private Unicode space it
might be an entity if it was your
favorite emoji in private Unicode space
but it isn't an entity for anybody else
maybe that was incomprehensible but
anyway this is clearly not a quick issue
all right well so those on the
livestream thanks for tuning in and
[Music]
there will be more exciting design
reviews soon okay see y'all soon yeah
all right